hey this is press tow
Walker this joke goes viral from time to
time and I've had many requests to cover
it a handwritten note with a bank card
is left on the
table hi darling use my ATM card take
any amount out go shopping and take your
friends for lunch the PIN code the
integral from 0 to 1 of the fraction 3x
Cub - x^2 + 2x - 4
all over the < TK of x^2 - 3x + 2 this
is multiplied by DX I love you
honey so we have a little bit of a joke
you're supposed to use the pin card but
you need to evaluate this ridiculous
integral so leaving the joke aside how
do you calculate this integral so this
is not something that's ever taught in a
normal classroom this is something very
difficult so so I did some research and
I found the technique is to use Oiler
substitution I would not have come up
with this by myself I saw it on math
stack exchange Oiler substitution is a
trick for evaluating integrals of the
form where you have a rational function
of X and the square root of the
quadratic ax^2 + BX plus
C so there many different versions of
this
substitution one version is you set that
square root of the Quadra equal to plus
or minus xti the < TK of a plus
T you end up with a function that'll
simplify we're going to use this first
substitution but there are other
substitutions that could be useful in
different problems so another one is x *
t plus orus the < TK of c a third
version is to take x - Alpha the
quantity multiplied by T and Alpha is
one of the real roots of this quadratic
equation
so in this particular integral take the
< TK of x^2 - 3x + 2 and set it equal to
x * the of a + t a is a coefficient on
x2 so it's equal to 1 so this is equal
to x +
T so how does this help
us so the first thing to do is to solve
this equation for
x so Square both sides of the equation
the x² terms will cancel out then bring
the -3x term to the right hand side and
the t^2 term to the left hand side so we
have 2 - t ^2 is equal to 2xt +
3x Factor the X on the right hand side
and divide through by 2T + 3 so we solve
for x in terms of T So X is equal to 2 -
t ^2 all over 2T +
3 now with this substitution we also
want to convert DX into DT so we can do
that by the quotient rule it's going to
be a little bit tedious but it's not too
difficult we also have an integral where
X goes from 0 to 1 so we need to change
the limits of integration so we evaluate
this and we get that t goes from the <
TK of 2
to1 so now comes the hard
part everywhere that you see X you're
going to want to substitute this
fraction
so you're going to have to make a lot of
substitutions furthermore this DX has to
be substituted in so this is going to be
a massive algebraic
exercise but you end up with the
following complicated
fraction so this is going to help us
even though it looks like the problem is
still very
difficult so now what do we do well we
can take 2T + 3 in the denominator and
set that equal to U this will simplify
things a little more so we can solve
this for T we can also say du is equal
to 2dt we change the limits of
integration so U goes from 2 < tk2 + 3
to
1 so doing this substitution where each
time we see T we solve for T in terms of
U and substitute in we're going to end
up with something that looks like
this so this is going to be something
that we can calculate the integral of
very
easily so we want this integral with the
limits of integration going from 2 < tk2
+ 3 to 1 so now we have a completely
manageable integral any student from
calculus should be able to solve this
integral so go ahead and take the
anti-derivative term by term and then
evaluate this integral from the limits
so just substitute in and simplify and
you end up with
1356 multiplied by the natural log of 2
< tk2 + 3 - 101 / 4 < tk2 and this is
approximately equal to-
2.98 presumably the pin is the first
four digits of the answer so you could
say the PIN code is
2981 so that is the long way to solve
the problem by
hand but I want to illustrate how you
can hack the answer numerically in
Excel so let's say we want to calculate
the area under the red curve going from
0 to
one one way we can approximate the
answer numerically is by using the
midpoint rule we will partition the X
into different
rectangles by specific width and we want
the height of each rectangle to be the
midpoint of the end points of each
rectangle if we increase the number of
rectangles we will get a better and
better approximation of the area under
the
curve so how do we do this in Excel so
I've created a blank workbook in Excel
and I've copied over the integral so
that we have it for reference how are we
going to numerically evaluate this
integral in Excel It seems impossible
but let's go ahead and do it we'll make
one column equal to the X values another
column will be the function values at
these X values then we want a column of
the midpoint of these X values then we
want the function evaluated at these
midpoints and finally we'll calculate
the area of each of these rectangles so
we start out where X is equal to
Z then we want some number of rectangles
so let's say we just start out with the
100 so we'll take the previous value + 1
/ 100 which is
01 now we want the function at each of
these points so we need a fraction where
we have 3 * X cubed so here we have X
cubed minus we take
x^2 + 2 * x - 4 and we need this divided
by the square T of x^ 2 - 3 * x + 2 but
here we go that's the function evaluated
at zero
now the midpoints will be the average of
these two x
values and the function at the midpoint
will just be the same function evaluated
at this midpoint so the formula can just
copy
over the area will be the width of this
rectangle that'll be the difference in
these X
values and we want it multiplied by the
function at the midpoint
so now we can just copy this formula
down and we're going to need to go all
the way until X is equal to one so let's
copy this down to about 100
rows oh and now we've learned something
interesting this is actually an improper
integral when X is equal to one the
function will be undefined no matter
we'll just delete these values
so now we want the area which will
exactly be the sum of the areas of all
of these rectangles so we just go ahead
and sum up the areas and we get
2.98 1 so we get pretty much the same
answer we got analytically but we found
it numerically and we found it pretty
easily in
Excel okay technically this numerical
answer will round to minus 2.98
82 but still we got an answer accurate
to two decimal places and if you wanted
a more accurate answer you could
increase the number of rectangles pretty
easily and use this method so it's quite
amazing that we can numerically estimate
integrals even in Excel One wonders if
our ancient mathematic forefathers would
have even gone through all the trouble
of calculating things by hand if they
had such numerical tools but these are
questions above my P
grade thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
[Music]
time